by the way the whack pack
did record questions for you
oh um but you know do you have time i
mean we've been yeah for two years
sitting in my house yeah who do you want
a question from first that be the [ __ ]
lady
oh
god ass napkin ed i know he's a favorite
of yours uh-huh
marianne from brooklyn yes
high pitch eric
bobo i've heard some of these questions
uh underdog ladies is particularly good
because she just is playing around with
you and uh wow and wench and wendy
they all prepared questions for you i
think we should close with wendy because
you know she's you know it's very
special to me but uh hey let's start
with underdog sure okay what do you
think i i bet you'll get this right what
do you think underdog is going to ask
you
i'm going to guess it has something to
do with wanting to appear on my show or
being angry that i did not contact her
about appearing on my show would you
seriously consider my
performing again
on your television show the way i did in
2006 i
i tried desperately writing and phoning
you
because um
2014 was underdogs 50th or golden
anniversary and
i was hoping you would
have me appear again for that purpose
but you blew it
[Laughter]
underdog wants to go back on your show
and perform a 30-minute 30-minute
dracula dance and a 15-minute breakfast
fashion show that's for real we when we
interviewed it we found that out
secondly she wants to appear around
halloween as her original character
spectrum the ghost king
oh and she also told us she is sure that
other guests have made multiple
appearances on your show so why can't
she so just be prepared okay she brings
up some very good points she does we're
actually we're hoping to save it for
underdogs 75th
one night when you're tired she's got 45
minutes for you
maybe she'd be a good guest host next
summer debbie the [ __ ] lady i asked
napkins
bobo
bobo i have i have a soft spot for bobo
because i really think he puts a lot of
thought into his questions okay here we
go
hi jimmy it's bobo jimmy you consider
yourself an outdoorsman
and you love all types of fishing
with that said
have you ever had sex with molly out in
the wild your thoughts ooh
i love how bobo seemed to know jimmy and
he was saying you're quite an
outdoorsman you know you go fishing no
one's waiting for a list
it's fishing and it's fishing he goes uh
you're quite the outdoorsman known for
all types of fishing
i mean there's only one type of fishing
one type of fishing one yeah well let's
see what marion cause i always feel like
marion doesn't really like me i i i
don't know what it is exactly but
there's there's
maybe it's oh i know maybe this is part
of it um
you were um when we were doing the show
in new york um
marianne was very anxious to come and
then um when we told her that you
weren't going to be on this time around
she said okay no thanks
of course
in fairness we were doing the show from
brooklyn where uh oh wait marianne is
from
brooklyn yeah literally across the
street okay let's see what she has to
say hi jimmy it's me marion from
brooklyn and i want you to be totally
honest what's one quirk of howard's that
gets on your last nerve
no i wouldn't say you get on my nerves
i would say that
um over the time that i've known you
the number of things that you think are
fun have been whittled down basically to
drinking hot water i mean it's like
we're and i i feel like we're going to
lose that eventually too
i mean drinking hot water is fun you
guys just haven't really understood the
fun of it
let's do wendy what's on wendy's mind
all right here let's hear this is your
your girlfriend wendy temple campbell is
there any way you can buy me a
that give courage to shop anywhere
wendy
if you get vaccinated
i'll get you a 500 visa gift card
that you can use anywhere
wow